you know you put you put range balls out
there and give somebody a club and
they're ready to play even though it's
raining here and you could have stayed
out there for a little while right
longer than I thought I thought it was
going to be two or three balls and then
you get hooked are you guys you guys got
the target yeah I was trying to make
Lenny one but are you competitive at
everything um even sleeping yeah yeah
pretty much I guess
in some way I mean you're wired that way
that somewhat wired that way I mean I
had an older brother who just leave me
up and told me I couldn't beat him in
anything so did you got revenge in a
variety of ways well we go selling out
we competed it does everything we were
kids so it was kind of a natural thing
and some of the fun and some was kind of
serious but you know I was able to be
applied to my sport obviously full intro
here Kelly Slater 55 career wins crowned
world surf league champion 11 times
including five consecutive titles 94 to
98 plan in the AT&T Pebble Beach pro-am
what's the best weather to surf in um
you just don't want too strong a wind
really that rain doesn't matter cold
doesn't matter what about waves it just
depends what you like I mean for a
beginner obviously something small like
as big as a table here but you know I
got friends that chase 60 80 foot waves
in fact of the waves in Portugal I think
today are really giant is that Nasser a
wave so I would expect to see waves was
probably 70 80 feet this afternoon have
you surfed in this area I have a little
bit there's some good little waves
around here a lot of guys surf right off
Spanish beta maverick of surf Mavericks
a couple times I've actually only ever
surfed it three times people are like
how do you like Mavericks like I mean
seriously I go yeah I surfed it three
times and I almost drowned twice but
what is what is that feeling like like
almost drowning um well I don't know how
close I was but um yeah I I don't know I
think it's super scary until it's like a
euphoric feeling you don't remember
anything q4 I pass out what's the
strategy when you're being held under
relax as much possible you know the
whole thing with with
being able to hold your breath a long
time is keeping your heartbeat down
keeping your gentlemen down you want to
be like calm you think surfing is kind
of an adrenaline sport but it's it's
really especially in big waves about
being calm and being relaxed and being
comfortable not letting the fear take
over and control what you're doing so
how long can you hold your breath for um
I don't know probably close to five
minutes for a half moon awesome really
yeah okay try it right now it won't be a
great interview but you'll be able to
watch this on TV when you call just I
will mine through this oh I like a great
well when did you know that this was
your calling um pretty early on not
necessarily as a profession but by the
time I was probably seven or eight and
when I was eight I first started
competing but prior to that I already
felt like surfing was going to be my
life in some way it was just something
we did every day it wasn't really a
career path back then I think the first
world champion in 76 or 77 guy named
Peter town and I think he wanted about
$2,000 that year not exaggerating and
the entire year the entire year yeah
and he was the best he was the world
champ at the end of the year and you
know before 1980 I don't think anyone
made more than maybe four thousand
dollars in a year competitively so it
wasn't it when I was a kid it wasn't
like I'm gonna grow up to be a pro
surfer it that really was more of a
lifestyle thing it wasn't like a career
path you know but when you say to your
family I want to be a pro surfer it was
well it was such a part as such a
natural part of our life that that uh
you know it was just it wasn't I know
there was never any pushback against it
you know my parents were super
supportive of everything we did what do
you put down on your tax return what do
you do for living human competitors hi I
put pro surfer every time I write that
all I can think of as a Tony Hawk book
Tony Hawk pro skater and that was
because it was you know what he always
put when he came through immigration but
but you two were similar I think in
bringing your sport into
the limelight sponsorship is there
parallels with you and Tony Hawk
um I guess there's some parallels and
it's in that we you know we had we both
had a longevity to our career and sort
of competitively been at the top for a
long time and but you know Tony as far
as action sports Tony was a guy who put
I would say all of us really truly on
the map with Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
and you know his video games became such
a household item for people and I don't
know if that was true or not but I heard
of I heard a rumor back when when that
launched and he was just ultra famous
that his was the most sought-after
autograph in the world for some period
of time really it was what I had heard
well let's just go with it I mean it's a
yeah my leg thank you didn't win
credibility I mean the one who wanted
Mandela you know there was don't know
what but just being a great surfer
translate into other sports are you
snowboarder like you knew can you do
other things
I got born I grew up skating so I'm not
a great skater but I was alright as a
kid and we should just build little
quarter pipes and half pipes around at
French houses and snowboarding didn't
really start until I was in my teenage
years but pretty quick it was pretty
quick to catch on I think for most
surfers is somewhat quick to learn he's
a Kelly Slater world champ
where's all your hardware you get like
all your trophies and everything
it's funny when when I was an amateur
and I probably won about 300 trophies
200 rupees and we had them like in a
pile behind a house from outside and
then we just kind of got tired of
looking at them so I kept I kept the
ones that meant a lot to me like a US
Championship or an East Coast title or
you know a few a few of the
international ones and then literally
put a pile of like marble and trophies
out on the road and remember somebody
coming collecting a whole bunch of
nobody well a lot of your trade I think
they were just taking the marble and
selling
I should have kept in myself well you
have a favorite surfboard um like if I
go to your house yeah or go to your
garage how many how many uh it let's say
you had to take one surfboard out of the
garage yeah
let's say it's on fire you got to take
one out boom is there one you take out I
there's I be a handful Oh would be you
know a couple under each arm I have a
board when I won my fifth world title
that al Merrick who is my shaper and
kind of like a second father to me al
made me just this board a hollow wood
board as a gift in that was in ninety
ninety seven and that's always been like
my sort of prized board I think in my in
my house I've written at one time I went
out in the middle of winter on the
coldest day and caught one wave in a
pair of trunks and okay I'll never ride
that board again so but it was a just a
gift he made for me special thing this
for the house you ever get to pants
during a ride lose your pants sure all
free ride yeah yeah free bone i've only
free road at night actually one time of
night circle did I know Mike so you
don't skinny dip you you surf nude I'm
in skinny dip before I know but this is
your version now later you know no yeah
Paulie do a video of uh Kelly it's going
up right here yeah because you were
actually looking to see if we have video
here naked here
I was actually that was I mean who
hacked my iCloud but you've never had
like a date where you're surfing at
night like that no oh okay
you know can you say can we break all
right now we'll combine by the way guys
want to know where you can walk my name
here I'm hanging around yeah you have to
flannel here yeah yeah the flannels big
talk this morning no it looks good thank
you are you wearing it to play in today
no I'm not this is just this actually my
clothing line so my goodness I got this
yesterday and I was like I like the know
my worth today looks good alright we'll
come back with Kelly Slater right after
this
eleven times he's won the world surf
League championship maybe you got one of
his trophies if you drove by his house
on the side of the real item and five
consecutive titles 94 through 98 where
do you get recognized more than other
places is there one spot in the world
where aside from an event that you're in
yeah
Brazil and Australia probably most like
but is this like fanboy crazy when they
see you on the streets I can be yeah I
mean especially around event and you
know if you're in one place for just a
week or something you know people
everyone knows your face and yeah it's a
little bit hectic strangers reaction
you've gotten from offensive oh gosh I
don't know I can't figure went off and I
signed a dog once yeah I don't know
there's there's weird ones though I had
a stalker years ago in France that was
really odd I mean literally like
straight out of like some bunny boiling
movie it was um she was like sleeping in
front of our hotel room and writing all
over the walls of the hotel in the
elevator in lipstick really scary it was
actually really frightening and she had
a young child like a you know an infant
sort of child maybe well when she
started but a few years later by the
time the kid was about five she was
still going it was really scary though
she would follow me like in my car she
see me driving follow me to the airport
or like to a restaurant and then stand
two feet away from me and take pictures
of me like non-stop it was really
bizarre you never caught a wave and all
of a sudden you look down and she's in
like snorkel gear or anything recession
not quite but she would stay at the
water's edge was fine she made stuff it
was really really out there did you
alert the authorities I tried to it one
day I was actually going through a lot
of personal stuff at the time and that
was just compounding it then I went to
the airport to try and get a flight out
just you know kind of a cold call just
I'm gonna go to the airport to the
flight and it was kind of just one
terminal airport and Bierut and she
followed me there and she was walking
through the airport there was no one in
the airport except for a security guard
and a couple people that worked at the
airlines and she was following me
through the airport taking picture of me
this far away
and and holding the chess sign even
there and she was like really like
really acting starstruck and but crazy
at the same time to me and trying to
tell the people there who I was in
French and and how great she thought I
was or something but it was like
psychosis it wasn't it wasn't just like
oh I love what you do can you sign this
great to meet you it was this was
something otherworldly Holly let's bring
out the stalker around her she's here
how much would you charge to teach let's
say an hour of service how much you got
how much do I have for ya our guest
would be 10 grand an hour if you rely it
actually I'm free I'm cheap nobody
somebody wanted to and no I I don't
think I would charge anyone to show them
how to serve I don't know
how long would it take for you to show
somebody else I'm a Soul Surfer man oh
oh okay no you could teach any of these
guys how to surf yeah no I you know to
learn how to surf the problem with
people who want to be a good surfer is
they want to start on they start on a
small little board that they can't work
with so when you start you just need a
big board looks like a boat basically
and then you got used to get used to
paddling and being able to judge waves
and especially obviously start on a
small wave and just get your confidence
up and learn just learn how to position
yourself and paddle for the wave of the
right time and that kind of stuff so you
don't want to be worried about like
sinking and you know the board won't
float that kind of stuff are you retired
no maybe I are you know
oh no no yeah I'm full-time still you
are yeah and how much longer if blood
but it feels like every the last couple
years it feels like there's been rumors
that you're retiring yeah there's been
rumors I've been you're tying for since
98 so why do they it's weird how people
you get to a certain point like Tom
Brady well is he going to retire you
know Peyton Manning's you're going to
retain you get an appointment people say
yeah you're going to retire that's
because that's what's happened I think
in the past with people when I got on
tour I'm turning 45 tomorrow when I got
on tour the oldest guy on tour was 28 or
29 so it kind of gives a little
perspective but it's it's
but it that also has to do with you know
my sport was young and guys weren't
really taking care of themselves they're
having a good time though but they
weren't really taking the sport
seriously like longevity longevity why
45 yeah so you know guys were kind of
party and having fun livin it up you
know get to travel around the world and
get paid it's pretty fun did you have
that streak stretch where you had fun
party a couple weeks though that no I
know I mean yeah I'd find I've had fun
here and there but I was so focused on
on I mean you're Baywatch days come on
yeah man I was partying Mariana you know
you learn oh I never really got into
that phase I mean here and there a
little a few drinks here and there
that's kind of thing for me i I've never
been I was so focused on competition and
winning and heaving goals and stuff that
that wasn't part of my deal ever have a
surfing hangover gone on the board when
you got a hangover oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's that's horrible
I've actually you know the in the old
school days like all the guys are my
heroes not all of them but yeah pretty
much all they I see him sometimes at
contests like they didn't sleep the
night before and they go straight out
and surf a heat kind of thing you know I
saw that a lot of times when I first got
on tour this is like you know around
1990 time and I mean you know guys are
young having fun shower gel and making
pretty good money and not really not any
obligation anything so what about trying
to explain your sport or what you've
accomplished
it feels like it's it's a it's a moving
target where somebody's trying to
understand how great you are with your
sport where we can say Tiger with golf
or Tom Brady with football or Michael
Jordan with basketball you're the most
decorated surfer in history but do
people understand or how do we
categorize that greatness I don't know
that's our conversation I shouldn't be a
part of it I mean I I know you're being
humble but I just trying because when I
die saying the first time you're on you
know I think people said always the
Michael Jordan of
surfing hmm are you I mean is that are
you just Kelly Slater surfing
hi I don't I don't know I don't know I
don't know answer these questions too
and to be honest yeah but right now my
mom's just beat it into me as a kid
don't talk about yourself you know like
don't talk about yourself like that it I
just if I write everyone of all innings
but and I thought I talked about you're
one of the great athletes one of the
great athletes that we think that we
have thank you and then people don't
understand okay well how do you explain
surfing and you know here judging it and
it's open to interpretation it is it's
every sport I mean how do you judge not
only sports a sport but also generation
to generation yeah you compare Ollie to
Tyson you know how you compare different
guys at different times you know can you
say Tiger Woods and Jack Nicklaus one's
better than the other they never really
went head-to-head so you don't see and
it was a different type of game and
equipment and you know things evolve and
change you know tennis went from kind of
a fuel sport to a power sport there's so
many different ways to play and do
things and then try to not only
generation to generation but sports
sport what you know if I'm are just like
you know football you tis hammer
somebody and you know or you're a great
pass or whatever and but just in
football how many different skills are
there you know there's a lot of
different skill sets you know one guy's
not doing everything so it some guys are
good guys become great or proficient I
think the great in sport are good at
most aspects of what they do like
they're at the top echelon of each other
different skills and you kind of have to
be to to to win for a long period of
time of you tougher surfing or golf gosh
I mean Golf seems so easy sometimes and
then it gets cold rainy at Pebble and
you feel like an idiot
yesterday I go saying yes did you feel
like an idiot I went out I went out two
days ago at Cypress and shot 74 and I
went out yesterday I think I shot 90
years more at Monterey Peninsula it was
just I just I'm just wasn't feeling it
was just like I said we started off
first hole three out of the four of us
put it in the bushes on the first hole
we started with a double bogey for the
team and I was saying I haven't done
that in like 12 years of playing Pebble
Beach
I don't think we've had one double bogey
ever in the whole time so it was just a
it was a tough day but you had one of
those moments where you get on the board
and you don't you know you don't have it
like you say yeah yeah absolutely yeah I
definitely have mornings I wake up and
I'm like I don't feel it and I mean I've
even literally gone home showered again
eat again start my whole day over like I
just not feeling it right you know you
got to brush it off almost lay back in
the bed for five minutes okay let's
start this again you know yeah but
that's life you know it's not just sport
that's just life everyone has bad days
so we appreciate your stopping by who do
you get mistaken for does anybody say
aren't you you ever get that not really
I mean called Christian Slater many
times
Christian Slater really yeah and I
wouldn't look nothing alike we have one
similar name Dennis Dennis Rodman Dennis
Rodman I swear every time I see the guy
hey Christian what's going on yeah hey
man yeah man have you been hanging out
with well he called me Craig Sager free
he never knew my name he say what's up
Sager and I started answering to him
after a while and I just like I'm not
even try to convince me let's call him
and let's Paul Sager hey yeah there was
there was I saw I saw a thing with
Dennis Rodman where there's a band
called live and yeah so he had known the
lead singer for like 15 years like man
cried wrong yeah yeah and it's on I'm
the wrong name again II dig I actually
call an Isaac he goes Dennis how long
have I known you
he's like 15 years and you still call me
the wrong name because that bed Edie
Edie Cole walls of all I don't know a
wall but yeah yeah I mean I don't blame
him for not know their last name but
yeah first names pretty easy
I could see uh maybe a younger Michael
Stipe Michael stay hmm lead singer REM
yeah guy of course I know who he is yeah
yeah thank you
like the don't embarrass yourself today
all right well it's all uphill it's all
down it whichever was easier today
easier thank you for sending me a
surfboard that we have in the man cave
before and we're all big Vince
yeah thanks you guys for having me I
mean not often likes to hang out with
jocks
it's Pebble Beach and that
about eight you he's not retiring he
said Kelly Slater he's got 11 titles
Kelly great great a VA something but the
Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]